buongiorno a tutti
è bello per me
e qui a parlare di accoglienza
io che
più di venti anni fa ormai a luglio
saranno 21 anni che mi dedico questo e
raccontarlo a voi che sarebbe il futuro
dell'accoglienza in italia abbiamo un
piccolo problema spesso che quello che
quando da ragazzini a 12 13 anni
cominciamo a pensare a quello che
potremo fare un domani
e diciamo ai nostri parenti voglio fare
il cameriere è qualcosa che viene visto
sempre come una scelta di serie b quando
invece chi fa questo lavoro lo sa questo
è un lavoro che ti fa giocare la
champions league due volte al giorno e
uno dei lavori più belli che possiamo
scegliere le possibilità di incontro di
viaggio di crescita che ci danno sono
enormi
l'accoglienza di forma prima di tutto
come uomini e poi come professionisti
sapete come si dice accoglienza in
inglese
chi l'ha detto
voce quindi si presume che chi faccia
questo lavoro sappia essere ospitale
sappia essere una persona capace di
creare atmosfera e non pensiamo al
lavoro pensiamo quando a casa
ospitiamo qualcuno per un aperitivo una
cena gli diamo delle regole prima di
arrivare a casa gli mandiamo una lettera
con delle regole
una mail un messaggio e ci aspettiamo
che una volta a casa nostra rispetti
quelle regole siano
ecco questo è il segreto il primo
segreto dell'accoglienza le regole
possono funzionare per un servizio
il servizio ha bisogno di regole ma
l'accoglienza no l'accoglienza è fuori
dalle regole
l'accoglienza non la possiamo
assolutamente codificare può crescere in
noi deve essere qualcosa che abbiamo
veramente dentro
pensate a quante volte si chiede oramai
lo vediamo dappertutto con gli chef in
tv chissà dove prende la sua creatività
dove è nata la sua passione
nessuno che si chiede perché qualcuno
decide di dedicare la propria vita al
servizio degli altri ed essere al
servizio degli altri
non è essere servili assolutamente è
proprio il contrario
quindi è lì la differenza le regole non
servono assolutamente quando facciamo
accoglienza perché l'accoglienza la
fanno le persone e per parlare di
accoglienza ho preso delle frasi di papà
francesco
il dialogo nasce da un atteggiamento di
rispetto verso un'altra persona della
convinzione che l'altro abbia qualcosa
di buono da dire presuppone fare spazio
nel nostro cuore al suo punto di vista
alla sua visione e alle sue proposte
dialogare significano accoglie rifà
cordiale e non una condanna preventiva
per dialogare bisogna sapere abbassare
le difese aprire le porte di casa e
offrire calore umano e quindi faccio vi
racconto un piccolo episodio che mi è
successo a piazza duomo era il secondo
anno che facevo il direttore 2016 è
arrivato uno dei clienti più difficili
che io abbia mai incontrato uno dei più
grandi economisti del mondo un kakà ci
siamo intesi
lui parlava solo con me li teneva al
tavolo anche 20 25 30 minuti aveva
determinato esigenze non mi portare gli
amori bush prima che ho scelto il vino
io non mangio e piccante non mangio
formaggio mia moglie deve mangiare
subito gli portate subito il pane aveva
approntato soltanto per una sera e io
non vedevo l'ora che quella tela finisse
perché a un certo punto era diventato
terrificante
non mi permetteva di allontanarmi dal
tavolo a un certo punto la signora
prende il telefono sta facendo una
chiamata loro sono americani e dopo 5
minuti credo la segretaria che vi si
sbraccia da fuori dalla sala
mi ha visto finalmente riesco a
staccarmi ha visto che mi fa ma questi
dell'otto non stanno bene dice mi ha
chiamato la segretaria dall america voi
immaginate qualsiasi ora fosse la
signora ha chiamato la segretaria in
america per chiamare al ristorante per
poter chiedere di riprenotare tutte le
sere che sarebbero rimasti in piemonte
io mi sono fatto il segno della croce e
torna tutte le sere no non è possibile
e tutte le sere stato così arrivava a
vincenzo avete il coraggio allora prende
una bella bottiglia stasera ma mela
passarvi kolko ravin così la finisco
domani e così è andato avanti tutta la
settimana mezz'ora al tavolo non mi
mollava non parlo con i camerieri voglio
parlare solo con te finisce la settimana
prima vera fine settembre riceve una
mail da lui direttamente niente
segretaria vincenzo torno in langa
voglio prenotare quattro cene da voi ho
bisogno che mi dà una mano a trovare
delle cantine perché poi è appassionato
di vino e quindi lui la macchina andava
in giro in bici per cantine poi la sera
veniva da noi ci scriviamo mi trovo gli
appuntamenti contentissimo eccetera
eccetera
torna un'altra persona cominciamo a
parlare con tutti niente più segretario
dell'america e la cosa bella è stata no
piccante pepe non formaggio all'ultima
se n'è andato via mangiando cacio e pepe
nel momento in cui è andato via ha
pagato il conto mi ha abbracciato e mi
ha detto mi mancherete non mi mancherai
mi mancherete il team quello per me è
stato ad oggi il più grande risultato
che ho ricevuto al lavoro proprio perché
la differenza la fa il calore umano è lì
che si costruisce il rapporto con il
cliente con chi ti sta di fronte
perché ricordate l'accoglienza non è
quello che facciamo con le persone per
le persone ma con le persone e questo
vale in qualsiasi ambito della nostra
vita
persone questo per me sta diventando uno
dei punti fondamentali perché diventi
direttore tanto qualcuno di voi aveva
fatto qualche esperienza già di lavoro
qualche stagione le vedete le madonne
volare i piatti mezzi sul fuoco vabbè se
un po meno ma io mi ricordo quando ho
iniziato io a fare stagioni i cuochi
mettevano i piatti sui fornelli per far
bruciare i camerieri e lì che sta il
futuro il nostro lavoro
no oggi sono sette anni che faccio il
direttore a piazza duomo
ai miei ragazzi ricordo una cosa
fondamentale è un altro che ricordo a me
quella fondamentale per i miei ragazzi è
che io non sono nato direttore non è che
un giorno è arrivato il padreterno ma ha
messo la mano in testa e sono diventato
il direttore tre stelle
anzi non ci credevo neanche non ci
credevo quando mi hanno chiamato la
prima volta a fare sto male perché non
gli avevo mandato il mio curriculum e
non ci ho creduto quando mi hanno
offerto la possibilità di prendere in
mano la gestione perché io sbaglio tutti
i giorni come sbagliano i ragazzi c'è
chi sbaglia da committee sbagliata chef
ed era anche sbagliato direttore è lì
che sta la crescita accettare i propri
errori andare avanti non credere di
essere immortali o superiori a chiunque
sia sarà nella lettera prima ha detto
una frase bellissima che dovete portare
con voi tutta la vita si è umile sempre
perché non sai chi chi hai di fronte a
te non sai quale stato d'animo le cose
più difficili da gestire per me non sono
stati servizi ne ho due che ne sono
successi degli ultimi anni un ragazzo
che dove venissero a lavorare da me a
inizio 2000 e 19 sapevo che sua mamma
stava male sua mamma è morta cinque
giorni prima che iniziasse a lavorare e
per me è stato più importante lavorare
sullo stato d'animo del ragazzo che
sulle sue capacità di saper raccontare
un piatto o di accompagnare un cliente e
nello stesso anno un come la mamma della
sua ragazza
incidente in macchina alle 10 mattina
alle undici e un quarto non c'era più
quelle sono le cose più difficili
da poter gestire perché non te le
insegna nessuno
sono quelle cose che dopo capisci che
non stiamo salvando nessuna vita il
nostro lavoro bellissimo accogliamo
serviamo grandi cucine ma allo stesso
tempo c'è gente che sta facendo molto di
più e quindi è lì che dobbiamo essere
umili e tenere i piedi per terra
l'altra cosa che invece ricordo a me
come vi ho detto prima buona alle
madonne
io oggi il desiderio che ho è quello per
cui per sé vero è che la gente che
lavora con me la mattina si svegli e
abbia voglia di venire a lavorare con me
io non voglio più vedere la gente che ha
paura che appena dc mezza parola o
perché hanno paura di sbagliare o perché
lì riprendi troppo ci va il giusto ma
oggi per me quella la cosa più
importante che è il mio cominio chef de
rang la mattina siano belli svegli
cazzuti andiamo a lavorare con vincenzo
e questo è lo spirito che io mi auguro
di poter di trasportare oggi di darvelo
e che lo possiate portare con voi perché
oggi c'è un grosso problema se vi non so
qualcuno s'è già linkedin linkedin nelle
ultime due settimane è stato un fiorire
di locali nel mondo non parliamo solo
dell'italia
londra aperto il 16 maggio la maggior
parte dei due tre stella londra aperto
senza personale felicità è messa di
mezzo la brex il fatto che lo sono stati
tutti gli altri lavoratori però non c'è
più nessuno che vuol fare straw lavoro è
brutto
io quello che sto facendo oggi al di là
del mio lavoro al ristorante quindi vado
in giro parlo insegno e per voi è perché
mi auguro che le vostre generazioni non
debbano affrontare la carenza di
vocazione che abbiamo dovuto affrontare
noi è già oggi abbiamo una classe
dirigenziale di ristoranti in italia
giovane figlia divertente perché il
nostro lavoro non è soltanto stare
chiusi in un ristorante il nostro lavoro
social il nostro lavoro e viaggiare io
due anni fa ho preso 32 voli ho visto a
singapore germania francia spagna paesi
baschi portogallo e ungheria
tutto nello stesso anno e questo e poi è
la e la cosa nascosta del nostro lavoro
che la gente non immagina la gente
continua a immaginare a fare il
cameriere
io ho visto fior fior di me coetanei che
poi sono uscito di casa che non avevo
neanche 14 anni più tardi mi coetani che
stanno ancora giù al paesello aspettati
disoccupazione al reddito di
cittadinanza
adesso non per parlare di questi
materiali viaggio mi diverto con le mie
passioni
una bella macchina sono tutti quegli
aspetti che nel nostro lavoro lui si
vedono beppe palmieri metterla
francescana sempre detto una cosa le
rubriche
pesanti le nostre rubriche del telefono
sono pesanti perché perché quando tu
gestisce un ristorante piccolo grande
che sia
arriva il giorno che sei pieno e c'è tal
dei tali importante o meno che ha voglia
di venire al ristorante e lì il tuo
telefono diventa pesante perché hanno
bisogno del tuo numero
perché tu sei la persona che in grado di
farli entrare al ristorante in quel
momento il nostro lavoro la nostra
figura le nostre figure sono figure
estremamente sfaccettate secondo voi
cosa c'entrano queste figure con il
nostro lavoro
se uno mi dice che un cameriere deve
essere un ninja ci credete vi faccio un
esempio banalissimo e questa è stata
un'altra bellissima che è successa san
valentino 2018 arriva un amen
dall'inghilterra prenotano per due è il
compleanno di mio marito
benissimo arrivano da noi devono
citofonare perché siamo al primo piano
citofonano entrano a riva il tavolo 82
uomini e mo il marito chi è di chi è il
compleanno è lì che diventiamo dei ninja
è lì che dobbiamo imparare in silenzio
invisibili ad ascoltare a carpire a
rubare le informazioni che ci servono al
cliente
a un certo punto dovevo entrare nel
tavolo perché mi serviva a capire di chi
dei due fosse il compleanno e ci si era
creata veramente un atmosfera di
confidenza a un certo punto hanno
pensato che anch'io fossi gay dovuto
sistemata che senza russo però è lì che
è stato il gioco con loro è stato creare
quella confidenza lì per capire
benissimo chi è il marito che fa il
compleanno estremo piccole cose in
realtà diventano enormi perché una
grande cucina oggi la potete trovare
ovunque da dalì ma fino a hong kong
ci sono tantissimi di quei ristoranti
grandi piccoli importanti o meno figli
la differenza oggi l'afa l'accoglienza
la fa quando sei in grado di creare
quell'atmosfera lì quando sei in grado
di far sentire qualsiasi cliente
importante tg rai tre stelle da una vita
chi non l'ha mai fatto e soprattutto voi
immaginate persona che gira i tre stelle
da trent'anni persona che non li gira e
ha risparmiato 18 mesi per venire da te
chi devo trattare meglio uguali
però se riesco un po meglio quello che
ha risparmiato perché non avrà
un'occasione a breve per tornare a
trovarmi riconosce c'è gente che si fa
magari 10.000 miglia in aereo per
trovare un ristorante
oggi il fenomeno dei destination
restaurant è un fenomeno importantissimo
per il turismo
dovremmo dovrebbero ricordarsi qualcuno
al governo dopo questo questo anno e
mezzo di pupi dove ci hanno ci hanno
obbligato a chiudere la stessa cosa
e per quanto riguarda dog sitter e baby
sitter tante volte capita che magari non
amiamo i bambini piccoli non amiamo i
cani invece quelli sono 22 strumenti di
conquista del cliente enormi io ne
parlavo proprio ieri coi miei ragazzi
perché abbiamo questa coppia che ci
viene a trovare più o meno da un anno e
mezzo un paio di volteranno che loro
hanno una cagnolina che ceca che si
chiama luce la prima volta abbiamo
conosciuto abbiamo giocato col cane
eccetera eccetera
quando sono tornati la seconda volta e
non c'era il cane ci ho messo trenta
secondi che mi si accendesse la
lampadina guardato la signora e lui ce
dove l'ha lasciata settimana scorsa
riceve una mail da un cliente irlandese
uno che si occupa di imprenditoria
veramente in maniera massiva perché lui
muove laboratori per grandi grandi opere
come lui ha fatto la metropolitana di
amsterdam e poi è socio di alcuni di
alcuni gruppi alberghieri nel nord
dell'africa tunisia marocco eccetera
eccetera
e lui mi ha scritto delle date eccetera
esser pronta re e poi ho visto che non
mi diceva del cane perché poi pro tav a
quello che aveva moglie la prima volta
il suo nome ma gli ho mandato una meglio
ha scritto ma il cane non c'è purissima
a memoria
quelle sono le cose che mi fanno
ricordare agli occhi del cliente
la stessa cosa neuroscienziato dobbiamo
applicarci a capire quali sono anche le
tecniche di vendita alle tecniche di
comunicazione perché sia abbiamo delle
persone ma comunque ristorante voi deve
avere del business che funziona e poi
sorride l ambasciatore principalmente
per il fatto appunto che dobbiamo essere
ambasciatori di un territorio di una
cucina dobbiamo conoscere dove siamo
conoscere il mondo ma allo stesso tempo
lo storyteller deve essere in grado di
capire quando il momento di fare un
passo indietro
quante volte vi è capitato di andare al
ristorante in due ed eravate in tre
perché il cameriere non si schiodava mai
dal tavolo invece bisogna essere giusti
nelle misure e nei tempi meglio una
parola in meno che se il cliente ha
piacere di chiederti qualcosa in più
tema chiede sempre perché ricordatevi
che stelle premi gambe la stella del
ristorante e il cliente gli stipendi li
paga il cliente
non li paga ristoratore senza clienti
ristoranti chiudono perché il cliente
importante non solo da quel punto di
vista c'è un trucco solo grande enorme
un cameriere non deve mai pensare da
cameriera deve pensare da cliente deve
ragionare da cliente che deve
comportarsi da cliente perché chi fa il
servizio il ristorante il bar quello che
sia lo vede a questa altezza guardi il
cliente no
il rientro è da questa e da questa
altezza qua si vedono difetti che
dall'altro lato non si vedono quindi
applicarsi studiare conoscere le regole
per poterci andare fuori ma
l'ingrediente vero dell'accoglienza
quello in più quello che fa la
differenza l'abbia detto prima e il
calore umano e il rapporto e queste cose
qui si presentano con una cosa sola
semplice immediata che tutti abbiamo
grazie
[Applauso]